[Music]
Giving the students better knowledge,
nurturing and
protecting
them If we adults lead them, it
will lead to peace in the demon world.
[Music]
This is this, this is the candidate for the self-demon king.
The words have different weight
after all, Bachiko-chan.  Please
continue to be my grandson's special lecturer.
Iruma-kun is a human being, so yes.
[Music] The only people who
know this fact
are the president, myself, and Professor Balam. I will
respect your will. Please
remember the conversation we just had.  Will you erase it or
protect Iruma-kun with us?
[Music] Good morning, Mr.
Opera. Today's breakfast looks like nothing.
[Music]
Today's breakfast is an omelet. Humans, it's
strangely neat, isn't it?
[Music]
I
mean, he's not a devil.
After all, that means he's the
only disciple over there. It ca
n't be helped. Whether it's a human or not, I'll take good care of him from now on.
[Music]
Running errands  I can't ignore what you do.This is
also part of my training, and I also use a calculator and clean the house.